I mean that the whole point of the era
no stock was proving that early
investors kind of just go off her gut
feeling so it's not super it's not like
a ton of research done into like the
person is at least that's how they lead
on but who knows how [ __ ] true that
is like I don't believe that every
single early investor just goes yeah I
like this guy's haircut and gives them
like a [ __ ] ton of money I think like
there can be like that I think it
definitely can it can but I would credit
her with being at least say it like Oh
sale savvy and no ya said she must have
been dude yeah that was one of the
things that blew my mind is that she the
amount of people she was able to [ __ ]
do mm-hmm
she was friends with the [ __ ] Obamas
you know the Clintons like she was like
at that level where she was like I you
know what's the phrase brushing elbows
or whatever bubble shoulders brushing
fishes bumping uglies with she's bumping
okay that's always he's bumping uglies
with the Clintons yeah she was she was
yeah just rubbing furries Clinton
rubbish she was dusting their cheeks
she's rubbing beans with hillary man and
like just just the amount like just
these powerful [ __ ] people this oh
yes I had in the palm of her hand what
reason the CEO of Safeway yeah that
[ __ ] a CVS yes yes yes yeah see both
and the who's that lawyer she got on her
team yeah that like he's like one of the
most powerful lawyers like a scary-ass
lawyer basically and you know her and
and the doc presents it that her whole
game was she was gonna do at the Edison
with it where the thing is not actually
completed and she's kind of working on
borrowed time and eventually they would
figure it out yeah who knows what that
was actually her game plan what I
thought was cool about the documentary
specifically is they
oh yes spoiler alert they know by now
that we just [ __ ] spoil everything I
just like saying it in the middle oh
yeah exactly I wanna say I shoulda said
it the yeah I was crazy man we're like
when she when she died like were you
remorseful at all or oh by the way
spoiler
now she's still very much alive that's
your life um unfortunately no one day
I'm kidding they so they wish death on
someone but she's [ __ ] she's [ __ ] a
lot of people's lives up oh yeah yeah
and he's a bad person now she doesn't
seem like a like a good person at all is
it you got the yeah I know that think
he's [ __ ] up sorry not so I um yeah
she I don't know the extent like the
details of it but I know at minimum the
people who worked there like she made
their lives really shitty did they did
it get into the dude who killed himself
yes that is crazy that is awful that is
[ __ ] awful and the patients that
would go in and get blood tests at CVS
yeah I would get these crazy results and
they thought they were dying and yeah
all cancer patients that like there was
that and they were providing incorrect
data to people testing for cancer yeah
like that [ __ ] when I know people that
were terminally ill with cancer that
were already going to die she was like
testing their they're like blood work
out on them and giving them bad results
oh I thought I thought it was that at
least in the doc I thought it was that
people were testing for cancer and the
results yes yeah that too and they were
trying to say no you're fine or like you
know like oh yeah it was vice versa but
whatever I mean yeah it's it's one way
or the other either way it's bad it
doesn't matter that when when it got to
the lab director who killed himself I
was like I have no Ives zero empathy for
this girl I don't dude middle of the
book you get to mid point of the book
and it like it only gets worse from
there and you're like I don't want to
keep reading because I [ __ ] hate this
girl so my dad Sonny uh yeah that her
husband or boyfriend /i gesture and I
mean like in it it's like I don't know
this book was just anecdotes from like
hundreds of people to the point where
you're like okay this stuff must be
[ __ ] true yeah you know yeah and
these guys is this guy is the [ __ ]
devil Elizabeth is they didn't hot they
didn't like talk too much about him I
mean I can only imagine he was a piece
of [ __ ] I they there was one girl who
worked in the lab and and she approached
Sonny and goes hey we were like getting
incorrect data and like I'm a Priya
like be issuing out this stuff and he
basically was just like that's not your
[ __ ] he's like you don't run this
company he just work here yeah how would
she shut your [ __ ] mouth
oh yeah he would just do that yeah and
she's like whoa okay I'm gonna [ __ ] all
of you over and he was also like he also
thought he was the [ __ ] because he sold
a company in the dot-com yeah like yeah
early yeah like he just built some
[ __ ] company and was like way to
even build it he was like a random like
CTO or something yeah and he got a
shitload of money oh yeah and then and
then like eight months later the company
that bought them went bankrupt anybody
made like thirty million bucks so then
he was like driving on his Porsche she
thought he was the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
guys sucked and and the guy shocks the
guy sucks - he stinks man you know it
was crazy was how they so they were
animating the device my [ __ ] god is
she driving unis stay mad there how am I
supposed to edit that down hate it what
down the screaming you don't have to
edit it down okay um there we go
clipping the mic is funny you're gonna
lose it yet when they were animating the
device and how it was supposed to work I
thought you always see these devices is
like being really slick I really [ __ ]
with this
I loved how they did this they took
those same animations and then
reanimated it as the engineers were
talking through all the problems so it
was really cool to see like all these
stages in like the demo you think oh man
what a seamless concept and it's just
like every stage how [ __ ] up it's
getting you're like oh this thing is a
piece of [ __ ] it's awesome like they're
like just describing how if you don't
know who the [ __ ] at Elizabeth Holmes is
or yeah yeah or what we're talking about
right oh yeah she'd say that she
basically started a company and her
whole Gulf theranos yeah and her whole I
think it was called fairness the rawness
is not the Rhinos I think it's called a
THC I think it's called that good
kadesha no no no aaron us whatever
theranos there knows who cares the point
is she started this company and she
wanted to revolutionize blood testing
and her whole and
was that she was only just gonna finger
prick your your finger and then get a
small amount of blood and then bail to
test that and administer antibiotics
based on the results or some [ __ ]
so like they're describing the machine
that engineers are talking through how
like small each of like the cavities are
like from the fingerprint like finger
prick devices and and they started
visualizing the blood cuz they were like
yeah it would definitely be it would
capture blood but they're like doesn't
mean it didn't leak and they're showing
like this machine leaking blood all over
these like compartments and like like
just little areas that they're not
supposed to be deposited into and then
the engineers like you know that was one
thing but then we started getting blood
samples from like random people people
who were hepatitis positive blood just
seeping all over the lab dude it's like
all over the machine and the engineers
like I was freaking the [ __ ] out because
I'm working on a device that has Hep C
positive blood in a [ __ ] thing that's
just got like tons of needles and I'm
having to work on it like cuz you know
it would be like testing in batches cuz
the whole thing is it would take like I
don't know [ __ ] 100 blood samples and
test them all and it's just it just so
funny I had never worked now ever never
it was it was always a piece of [ __ ]
like unicorn thing it was it was
completely fake I wonder if Steve Jobs
ever like if he if he knew how many
[ __ ] stupid wannabes would just [ __ ]
up the world after he was gone yeah
if he'd be pissed about it you know all
right some weird like open letter he was
like just don't try to be me you're not
gonna do it oh they all heard she was
obsessed with him her corny ass like
just dressing like him I know which is
like I know certain boys it's like hey
you're not Steve Jobs yeah do your own
thing
you're a smart girl and you clearly are
talented and [ __ ] getting people to
do what you want you're manipulative
like yeah and that could be used for
good yeah just just don't like just yeah
I was talking I was talking about this
with my dad do you think like if she had
started any other company she would have
been successful probably oh yeah cuz it
didn't involve like death yeah me cheap
I wouldn't be the
you know world's youngest self-made
billionaire woman or whatever she got
named as when the Rhine house was in its
peak but she would be successful
[Music]